[Musique]
je sais que mon père m'a fait du mal
la première fois au dessus de voix c'est
quoi une flotte parce que c'est enfin
l'ailier tellement été désirée ce moment
qui arrive chez toi l'enfant
on constate comme le sien même si au
fond de notre tête on sait jamais ce qui
peut arriver
je sais maintenant justin ces nouvelles
familles
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
derrière cette famille aujourd'hui
joyeuse se cache d histoire troublante
des enfants québécois en manque d'amour
qui ont trouvé des parents d'exception
prêt à tout pour leur offrir enfin une
vraie famille un peu comme tout le monde
voulait avoir nos propres enfants avant
d'être réellement mais bon il faut la
vie nous amène des surprises le couple
décide d'entamer un processus d'adoption
non pas à l'international mais ici au
québec auprès de la direction de la
protection de la jeunesse
la dpj un des mythes qui perdurera
encore au québec parmi la population
c'est qu'il est impossible d'adopter un
enfant qui réside au québec alors que
c'est il faut
en effet en moyenne 300 enfants
québécois sont adoptées chaque année
parmi eux il y a des enfants
volontairement donné en adoption par
leurs parents mais la vaste majorité des
enfants ont été retirés à leurs parents
par la dpj
c'est ce qu'on appelle la banque mixte
c'est vers cette option que le couple
s'est tourné pour éviter de trop longs
délais au québec c'est plus facile
d'avoir un premier contact rapide
c'est ce pouvoir un peu c'est une petite
lumière dans l'ancien la bien éveillé
tout ce malgré le son lourd bagage dans
la banique ce sont tous des enfants qui
ont un parcours de vie 4 ce sont tous
des enfants qui ont vécu des événements
traumatisants qui ont été victimes
d'abus de négligence de maltraitance au
début du processus
la dpj fait une évaluation psychosociale
rigoureuse des postulants de leur côté
les parents remplissent des formulaires
afin de définir le profil de l'enfant
qu'ils sont prêts à adopter par exemple
un enfant qui a été abusé sexuellement
qui à l'handicap physique ou qui est né
d'une mère toxicomane alcoolique
le but réaliser le meilleur jumelage
entre les parents adoptifs et l'enfant
qui a des besoins particuliers comprend
que pour certaines personnes ça peut
heurter parce qu'on a l'impression de
choisir un art temps de magasiner
mais c'est un outil pour nous qui est
essentiel pour pouvoir les biens les
accompagner bien les souvenirs on est
capable de tolérer un enfant qui ont des
handicaps mais qui sont récupérables
le premier qu'on a eu un enfant qui
était chez qui nous sépare c'est
d'entendre
ça m'a cassé une jambe puis 24 fracturé
les côtes
heureusement pour ces dre séduit marqué
par la violence allait prendre fin le
premier regard comme tombe en amour et
vérité mignon après une longue attente
de 16 mois pour rencontrer un enfant le
couple choisi d'accueillir le petit
cédric âgés de huit mois et demi
toutefois les défis que doivent relever
joël et sylvain sont grands pans de
magané hémiparésie médecin fracture ça
donc il fait outre remonter ça en plus
de créer un lien n'attache pas photo de
phares sont des chanceux y avait pas de
visites familiales
la plupart du temps les parents
biologiques ont des visites supervisées
avec leurs enfants ont pu sembler
travailler sur deux fronts mais je vous
dirais qu'on travaille sur le front
parental tout temps par respect pour cet
enfant que dans son intérêt travail et
un plan b si le plan acquis de retourner
chez maman et papa ne fonctionne pas la
très très grande majorité des enfants
lorsqu'ils intègrent une famille
d'accueil banque mix ni ressorte plus
c'est probablement odin 90% mais
peut-être plus pour certaines régions un
an après l'arrivée de cédric alors
qu'ils attendent toujours que son
adoption soit officielle sylvain et joël
font une nouvelle demande d'adoption
quelques mois plus tard tristan victime
de négligences de la part de sa mère
biologique arrive dans la famille mais
eux
débuts difficiles c'est un enfant qui
s'est promenée beaucoup le famille
d'accueil et qui avait beau y avait créé
beaucoup de méfiance envers les adultes
qu'est ce que tu sais sur la première
famille ta famille biologique est il si
peu près pas moi c'est en fait être
capable de lâcher prise et de contrôler
ses émotions des qualités essentielles
pour adopter à la bande mixed up on
cherche pas des gens parfaits bien au
contraire on cherche des gens qui ont un
parcours de vie où ils ont eu à
surmonter des obstacles et on regarde
mais comment ils ont surmonté ces
obstacles
le but étant de déterminer comment ils
vont pouvoir aider nos enfants à
surmonter leurs propres obstacle une
petite fille manque dans le portrait de
famille le couple dépose une troisième
demande restée chez nous un an et
quelques mois
le prêt à marcher avec nous elle prépare
les avec nous mais le père biologique
s'est graduellement repris en main la
journée que les troubles sociaux annoncé
que
redonner la guerre d' eau par ce qu on a
pleuré toutes les larmes d'un quart mais
c'est le risque d'adopter au québec sont
savait dès le début que ce ne soit
capable on accepte ça on a vécu affirmé
comme un deuil la perte d'un enfant le
dis bonne chance ma chouette pire on
sent vers un jour malgré la douleur joël
et sylvain sont prêts à se lancer à
nouveau et cette fois une chance inouïe
s'offre à eux
une fillette qui n'a plus aucun contact
avec sa mère biologique
on ne peut l'a montré à la caméra
puisque l'adoption n'est pas complété
enzo rappelé le faut nous offrir une
petite fille âgée de trois semaines
hello c'est moi qui avais pris l'appel
puisque j'avais les larmes aux yeux mais
par an 10 et 100 % maintenant à l'heure
on va bientôt l'adapter pour ce qui est
de tristan et de cédric c'est officiel
après une aventure qui aura duré trois
ans sylvain et joël ont reçu leur
jugement d'adoption c'est le tapis le
plus important c'est la confirmation
d'un jugement d'adoption
ça ça veut dire que plus de possibilités
que la dpj où les parents reviennent sur
leur décision
c'est le bonheur total neveu est réalisé
d'avoir un enfant à naître l'adoption
n'est pas un droit au québec c'est un
privilège c'est un privilège que les
adultes ont d'accompagner ces enfants
qui ont peu reçu beaucoup dans leur vie
qu'ils ont tout à recevoir ça prend des
forces particulières et ne suffit pas
d'être un bon parent pour être un bon
parent de confiance très très très fier
toutes les trois en face à mons fabien
sauce très fiable que je recommencerai
l'importateur ça change vraiment une vie
on est plus juste nous deux bulles un
coffre sévèrement une femme élise
[Musique]